another incredible woman in las vegas is
jovan johnson she's making strides in
the construction industry
now she was introduced to carpentry back
when she moved to vegas in 2002
while she was volunteering for habitat
for humanity
johnson says she really wanted a new
career with solid income
to keep herself afloat as a single mom
now she says there is
nothing she'd rather be doing i never
would have ever
imagined 20 years ago you told me this
is what i was doing
i would have thought you were crazy but
um
here i am you know 17 18 years later
and i do what i love i absolutely love
being a carpenter johnson now works as a
local carpenter union rep who oversees
all of the union's committees that
include sin city sisters which is a
committee
of all female carpenters that works to
support other female-centric
organizations
across the valley we wish happy
international women's day to jovan
johnson
to denise valdez sally jeremiel and all
the women that might be watching right
now
and how about lauren our producer in the
control room good call dee